Caption: afternoon amazing people here at DDD
Caption: Perth it is my pleasure to introduce our
Caption: next speaker Anton ball he's talking to
Caption: us today about superhero layouts so I
Caption: hope we get a few superhero poses from
Caption: him
Caption: he is a front end developer speaker and
Caption: Community organizer including here at
Caption: DDD Perth he's passionate about clean
Caption: and structured code web standards
Caption: accessibility and optimization and Anton
Caption: Prides himself on delivering robust high
Caption: quality and beautiful Solutions
Caption: Anton co-organizers fenders front and
Caption: developer meetups and as I said DDD
Caption: Perth he's also volunteered as a mentor
Caption: introducing
Caption: into this wonderful world that is coding
Caption: take it away Anton cool
Caption: so
Caption: thanks everyone for coming along I've
Caption: got the uh sponsor slides up there so
Caption: that's good that they help us to have
Caption: this event for
Caption: pretty great price really
Caption: so I'm going to be talking about
Caption: superhero layouts uh
Caption: Comics are said to have passed through
Caption: four ages with each of the ages known to
Caption: have something distinctive about it
Caption: in the Golden Age we were first
Caption: introduced to the superhero archetype
Caption: this was around about 1938 or so
Caption: this was our introduction to characters
Caption: like Superman Wonder Woman and Batman
Caption: during the Silver age the world is
Caption: recovering from a World War and readers
Caption: had matured during that time so to meet
Caption: that maturity the stories were focused
Caption: on horror crime and romance more than
Caption: what they were before
Caption: this sort of helped the industry to
Caption: survive through what was a difficult
Caption: period
Caption: after the Silver age many of those
Caption: heroic storylines that the writers could
Caption: think of were used so they decided
Caption: instead of Bronze Age to tackle the
Caption: social issues of the day this would
Caption: include bigotry racism and substance
Caption: abuse
Caption: and the modern age is a time of
Caption: redesigned growth and some disruption by
Caption: the web
Caption: anyone can publish now bringing more
Caption: unique stories and making Comics more
Caption: accessible than to audiences than ever
Caption: thought possible no longer was it about
Caption: a couple of those major players that
Caption: were creating or publishing comics
Caption: and so what makes Comics an absorbing
Caption: storytelling medium is that along with
Caption: great characters stories and art styles
Caption: is the impact that the layout can have
Caption: on that story
Caption: and we're going to explore each of the
Caption: ages of comics and how it relates to web
Caption: layout and how CSS grid combined with
Caption: some other CSS techniques can be used to
Caption: recreate these layouts and as you're
Caption: looking at these they're obviously very
Caption: comic book Focus but think about how you
Caption: can reimagine the techniques that I'm
Caption: talking about here for the use in your
Caption: layouts and projects that you're working
Caption: on
Caption: and I'm not going to dive too much into
Caption: responsiveness I think there's a lot of
Caption: great articles that cover that with grid
Caption: already but it is possible to do so and
Caption: there's a short part here where I will
Caption: cover it so those comic book ages that I
Caption: went through spanned about 70 years and
Caption: so many years is a fairly long time to
Caption: be able to evolve a storytelling medium
Caption: by comparison our industry the web is
Caption: still relatively young HTML is about 29
Caption: years old and CSS is 25 and that makes
Caption: me older than both of them unfortunately
Caption: not combined but that's still okay
Caption: so the web is after all young and so if
Caption: anyone else is older than them so are we
Caption: but the point I'm getting at to here is
Caption: in a relatively short period of time
Caption: layout on the web progress through many
Caption: ages of its own we started off with just
Caption: HTML this was the text links basic
Caption: elements
Caption: we sort of co-opted tables to do what
Caption: they weren't really meant to do and we
Caption: started using them for layouts the first
Caption: of our comic book crossovers flash came
Caption: along gave us very Dynamic layouts but
Caption: it had its own problems and we've been
Caption: going through absolute float responsive
Caption: and I think we're kind of heading into
Caption: the intrinsic era which is a term that
Caption: I've seen Jen Simmons coin that's
Caption: talking more about letting the devices
Caption: Define the layout a bit more we have
Caption: foldable phones we have fridges
Caption: all sorts of things
Caption: so all that in 29 short years less than
Caption: half of that of our friends in the comic
Caption: industry so it can be really tempting at
Caption: times to give layout on the web a hard
Caption: time but given the relatively young age
Caption: that our industry is I think it's
Caption: amazing how far we've progressed and we
Caption: can certainly appreciate what we have
Caption: now when you consider where it is that
Caption: we've come from
Caption: so is the current age of the web going
Caption: to be considered the web's Modern Age
Caption: and with CSS grid I think that might
Caption: just be the case
Caption: so before I jump too much into code this
Caption: is me Anton ball uh I'm local here to
Caption: Perth and I've always kind of brought my
Caption: daughter along to these events so you
Caption: might see me rocking around with her a
Caption: little bit more later
Caption: and as you know I'm older than HTML and
Caption: CSS I'm a full stack team lead at doist
Caption: we make todoist and twist applications
Caption: you can find me on Twitter at Anton JB
Caption: if you want to and perhaps this is extra
Caption: information at this point but I quite
Caption: enjoy comics
Caption: so undoubtedly one of the most important
Caption: comics in history is Action Comics
Caption: number one this was as I said released
Caption: around 1938 and what makes it an
Caption: important comic in the history of all
Caption: Comics is it's the introduction of
Caption: Superman and just so we're all clear
Caption: that's him holding the car up there now
Caption: Superman has changed a lot through the
Caption: years but this is where they started
Caption: the layout throughout the comics and
Caption: others even in the golden and silver age
Caption: consisted primarily of rows of squares
Caption: and rectangles if we look at a few of
Caption: the pages from the comic we can see that
Caption: pattern in use we'll have a couple of
Caption: squares a long larger rectangle with the
Caption: uh in it but what we are focused on is
Caption: layout so I'm going to strip out the
Caption: imagery and see what we are left with
Caption: the pattern was one to three panels per
Caption: row staggered throughout the page with a
Caption: somewhat consistent Gap it was printed
Caption: so you know somewhat consistent in terms
Caption: of CSS Grid it's a nice starting off
Caption: point we might think that we can do grid
Caption: template rows and sort of repeat three
Caption: times over one fraction but
Caption: we need to go a little bit further if we
Caption: want to achieve the Staggering that we
Caption: can hopefully see here can you actually
Caption: see the Staggering
Caption: it's can you see the gray squares I
Caption: suspect not
Caption: um oh all right
Caption: so the way I calculated the columns is
Caption: to measure the smallest panel on the
Caption: layout and divide that by the width of
Caption: the comic so the smallest panel would be
Caption: between two gaps there that you can see
Caption: we aren't using that size but it gives
Caption: us the basis with which to work from so
Caption: between two panels is there don't worry
Caption: more color comes in later
Caption: so when we divide the page width which
Caption: is 576 by the 36 which is the smallest
Caption: panel we could possibly do that gives us
Caption: a total number of columns we would want
Caption: to recreate this layout importantly it's
Caption: the same aspect ratio as the printed
Caption: version
Caption: so turning that into grid we have
Caption: display grid grid template columns
Caption: repeat 16 times over one fraction
Caption: and the grid Gap we can be super
Caption: consistent now because we're in the web
Caption: so
Caption: we don't need grid template rows in this
Caption: example because we can rely on the
Caption: implicit grid to handle that for us
Caption: and so what do I mean by the implicit
Caption: grid if we were to fill up all of the
Caption: contents along that first defined grid
Caption: grid will automatically add a new track
Caption: to the row underneath which will fill up
Caption: with those columns as well and by
Caption: default the implicit grid tracks are
Caption: automatically sized
Caption: we can start controlling that if we want
Caption: to with grid Auto rows or grid Auto
Caption: columns but for the purposes of our demo
Caption: we're happy for the grid to just keep
Caption: repeating over as we use it
Caption: and each panel can then span the number
Caption: of columns required there so panel one
Caption: spans across six panel two spans across
Caption: five and we start to get the layout of
Caption: our grid with the Staggering so there we
Caption: go we've created a comic layout with
Caption: only a few lines of CSS and the
Caption: Staggering is a nice touch to avoid
Caption: being too symmetrical in layout we never
Caption: want it being all the same
Caption: but it's while it's not much code for a
Caption: lot of possibilities we aren't really
Caption: feeling like superheroes just yet
Caption: so the layout and action comic one
Caption: didn't play a huge role in the story
Caption: itself so it's it's more used as a
Caption: container and that was about it
Caption: so let's instead jump forward to the
Caption: Bronze Age which brings it with a change
Caption: in how layout did become a part of the
Caption: story
Caption: Spider-Man 121 was released around 1973
Caption: and considered a pivotal point in this
Caption: character's sort of story arc and their
Caption: history
Caption: now I hope it's not a spoiler for
Caption: something from 1973 but this is the
Caption: death of Gwen Stacy which if you've seen
Caption: any of the movies lately you're probably
Caption: familiar with it we can talk about it
Caption: later
Caption: so what's great about this story along
Caption: with the moment artwork and everything
Caption: involved is the way that the layout
Caption: became an integral part of its telling
Caption: the height of the bridge in the fall is
Caption: shown beautifully through those spanning
Caption: panels
Caption: you wouldn't get that sense of height or
Caption: danger from the grid if it was like the
Caption: previous example all running along
Caption: several rows
Caption: so even though it's a great moment in
Caption: there let's again strip out the artwork
Caption: and see the layout in use
Caption: so the big difference is the panel
Caption: spanning multiple rows this is one of
Caption: the areas where grid has given us a
Caption: sense of a modern layout we no longer
Caption: are we constrained to a single axis and
Caption: the way that I determine the panels was
Caption: done as the same in the previous one
Caption: this time though we have 23.
Caption: so we're still able to rely on implicit
Caption: grid even though we're spanning multiple
Caption: rows now
Caption: uh because grid will allow us to do that
Caption: so we add in panel one we span across
Caption: nine like we did before but now we can
Caption: span down three rows and grid will
Caption: handle that panel two will span across
Caption: seven panel three uh will be whatever
Caption: the rest of 23 minus nine and seven is
Caption: and then panel four will just slide into
Caption: place there grid gives us a lot of
Caption: things for free which is nice and we
Caption: were able to Now cover a great many of
Caption: the layouts during and up to the Bronze
Caption: Age
Caption: so next up in the Journey Through the
Caption: Ages is Watchmen which famous for many
Caption: reasons like the movie but it kicked off
Caption: The Modern Age of comics now Watchmen
Caption: adhered to a strict nine panel grid
Caption: throughout its run which means what
Caption: we've created so far would essentially
Caption: cover this whole comic book or this
Caption: series
Caption: so there's hundreds of possibilities
Caption: with a nine panel grid which is not me
Caption: recommending everyone go out and do that
Caption: it just means that it's very powerful
Caption: but there was a panel from Watchmen that
Caption: I wanted to recreate it did something
Caption: just a little bit outside the box with
Caption: grid
Caption: now the panel in the middle there it's
Caption: there's a lot going on with the speech
Caption: bubbles but the artwork you can see is
Caption: the same image running across the three
Caption: panels it's not just constrained into
Caption: one anymore
Caption: now we could split the image into three
Caption: if we wanted to it would make it quite
Caption: easy but I think it's better if we can
Caption: recreate the effect while we maintain
Caption: the image
Caption: it'll give us some flexibility so if we
Caption: want to swap the image out later we're
Caption: only going to have to do the one and not
Caption: remember all the various steps and
Caption: cutting them up into three
Caption: or if we want to work with some
Caption: responsiveness which we'll see in this
Caption: one
Caption: so the setup here is similar to what we
Caption: had before where I'm aiming to have the
Caption: image remain intact while we add the Gap
Caption: in there
Caption: so panel three which is in the middle we
Caption: are going to wrap that in another grid
Caption: so we have our main grid laid out like
Caption: we have before and panel three has a
Caption: grid in there as well and it's spanning
Caption: multiple columns so we have room enough
Caption: to place the gap
Caption: now only the direct children of a
Caption: container can become grid items but with
Caption: subgrid we're able to inherit the rows
Caption: or columns from the parent element
Caption: now that's what happens here when we add
Caption: subgrid onto the overlap area
Caption: so we'll look at it without the image to
Caption: try and better understand what's
Caption: happening overlap is pulling in the rows
Caption: from the main comic itself with that
Caption: subgrid
Caption: but we don't if the comics sorry if the
Caption: columns in the main comic one were to
Caption: change if we were to add more or change
Caption: it to be a different ratio then the sub
Caption: panel or overlaps or I would inherit
Caption: that so we're getting that just for free
Caption: but we don't have to inherit the whole
Caption: Grid in this case we can set our own
Caption: rows in there as well so we can only
Caption: inherit what we want and leave the rest
Caption: out now why that might be useful is if
Caption: we were to say add the speech bubbles in
Caption: we're going to have a better chance of
Caption: positioning them on the page
Caption: so putting the graphics back it's time
Caption: to achieve the Gap in there
Caption: we do this with a pseudo element we add
Caption: that to the overlap container in there
Caption: we give it the same
Caption: graphic visuals as the outline so we
Caption: give it the same grid Gap and the same
Caption: coloring I've just used a custom
Caption: property there just to kind of give an
Caption: example of how that could be easier
Caption: and put it into place
Caption: and so there we go that's ticked off our
Caption: goal of maintaining the image while
Caption: simulating a grid Gap now if we wanted
Caption: save for mobile for a little bit of
Caption: responsiveness we could drop that Gap
Caption: off and just have the whole image there
Caption: if we were thinking outside of just
Caption: Comics here
Caption: so subgrid is a great next step for grid
Caption: anytime you've struggled to align items
Caption: without setting the height across
Caption: multiple panels and I'm sure if you've
Caption: ever done front end you've probably had
Caption: those three panels and there'll be some
Caption: headings on the top and some content in
Caption: the middle and some of them will have
Caption: like only a tiny bit of text and then
Caption: the other one's like a short novel and
Caption: they all get stretched out so with
Caption: subgrid we'll start to be able to
Caption: inherit across rows or across columns
Caption: and keep them consistent
Caption: this is an example from the todoist
Caption: website where we run into this so I've
Caption: used the German language here because
Caption: they're always good for like long words
Caption: that you can test with these areas so if
Caption: we set height we run the risk of cutting
Caption: the text off or having that overlap if
Caption: we set a minimum height well then we
Caption: have the weird sort of thing where now
Caption: the buttons aren't lining up and if you
Caption: have the designs they typically will
Caption: line up
Caption: so we're running we have that problem so
Caption: grid and subgrid are going to have us
Caption: covered if the middle content was to
Caption: grow the others will grow in all three
Caption: panels it'll be very handy and the
Caption: advantage over the flat grid setup is we
Caption: get the flexibility of the expanding
Caption: rows while we get to maintain the
Caption: semantic relationship of each of the
Caption: elements each one can be in its own
Caption: semantic div or whatever it may be and
Caption: we're covered
Caption: but where's browser support at with some
Caption: grid
Caption: not not great
Caption: we're still a little bit in experimental
Caption: territory here and and that's okay you
Caption: can still sometimes use it the only
Caption: browser with subgrid sort of fully
Caption: implemented is Firefox as in released
Caption: and they actually did it all the way
Caption: back in 2019 the day after I gave this
Caption: talk once they did it
Caption: that's Safari recently enabled subgrid
Caption: in the technical preview that's why I
Caption: said Firefox is the only one but it's
Caption: it's in there which means by the next
Caption: versions of safari we'll start to see
Caption: subgrid
Caption: but there is hope in all of this subgrid
Caption: has been included in interop 2022 which
Caption: is a combined effort by browser vendors
Caption: and people that also write code for
Caption: supporting web standards to close the
Caption: gap in some of these CSS features uh so
Caption: they are all going to basically work
Caption: towards having subgrid implemented and
Caption: passing the same test so that it is
Caption: displayed correctly across all of the
Caption: browsers
Caption: before that though and before subgrid is
Caption: more widely available we can recreate
Caption: this effect with display content so
Caption: we've added that to overlap and
Caption: essentially what it does
Caption: is get rid of that container in there
Caption: and lifts the items up into the parent
Caption: grid which is our comic
Caption: we do lose the semantic meaning though
Caption: which is why I think subgrid is going to
Caption: be a better option for us if we had some
Caption: very specific semantic meaning by adding
Caption: the display contents it's gone
Caption: so that can be a bit of a problem
Caption: now it's the next Evolution during the
Caption: Modern Age of comics where layout really
Caption: gets creative and interesting where
Caption: revisiting the world of Spider-Man here
Caption: we'll do that a few times because it's a
Caption: bit of a favorite of mine but we started
Caption: to see a new trend in this age of comics
Caption: This Modern Age brought with layering
Caption: panels to achieve a flow and depth that
Caption: we hadn't previously seen
Caption: artists were able to focus in and
Caption: provide little detail elements without
Caption: taking up all the space that others had
Caption: now layering's certainly not new to the
Caption: web but grid enables us to layer in much
Caption: easier and predictable ways than with a
Caption: previous option so let's take a look at
Caption: some of the code
Caption: we have display grid we have grid
Caption: template columns and then we have all
Caption: these numbers and it's like wow yeah
Caption: that's so much easier than what it was
Caption: before
Caption: but here's how I figured it out and if
Caption: you have the artwork that can be useful
Caption: which we often do with from the uh the
Caption: friends in design or if you design
Caption: yourself
Caption: and we'll focus on the rows so there's
Caption: the number of rows that we have is nine
Caption: we have nine we have that we want to
Caption: place out in here now this is starting
Caption: to look like a similar trend if we
Caption: divide the height by the number of rows
Caption: we get a base for one fraction unit so
Caption: we can do this with one of the panels as
Caption: well we can use that as one fraction but
Caption: this is the way that I kind of went for
Caption: it
Caption: so next we divide the height of an
Caption: individual row by that base fraction
Caption: so 291 is the row we want 109 is the
Caption: base unit that we're using and that
Caption: gives us 2.6 fraction units
Caption: so what what are these fraction units
Caption: and why are we do we keep using them in
Caption: Grid they give us a bit more flexibility
Caption: when we need to make everything
Caption: responsive and maintain the aspect ratio
Caption: and also if you can't really use
Caption: percentages because we have the Gap
Caption: value in Grid as well and if you use
Caption: percentages with gaps things will start
Caption: to get weird and over overlap but if we
Caption: use the fractions it's going to stick
Caption: within those bounds and the gaps will
Caption: also help to stick it in there or they
Caption: will they will work together with gap
Caption: rather than against it and we repeat
Caption: that same process to determine the
Caption: columns
Caption: so there we go that's how we got to all
Caption: those numbers
Caption: now we can then layer our panels over
Caption: the top where needed using grid row and
Caption: grid column values so our panel three
Caption: which has the young lady in it we have
Caption: grid Row 4 to 7 and grid column five
Caption: span one and Z index just to bring it up
Caption: onto the top now panel four we have grid
Caption: row five through to nine so we're saying
Caption: from five to nine but interestingly we
Caption: have grid column two to negative two
Caption: so where does this negative 2 come from
Caption: in here the grid lines each of the lines
Caption: in a grid are numbered one through to n
Caption: in our case that's eight the total
Caption: number of lines that we have so the
Caption: starting line for panel four is two we
Caption: wanted it a little bit in
Caption: but those lines are also numbered in
Caption: Reverse so from what would be our
Caption: typical reading order from the right is
Caption: negative one through to negative n or
Caption: eight
Caption: so if we want to lay uh finish up two
Caption: lines in we can use negative two the
Caption: benefit of that is when inevitably our
Caption: design changes later on if more lines
Caption: were to be added into the middle we
Caption: don't have to update everywhere that we
Caption: do it if we said span to the distance we
Caption: want and then we add something new well
Caption: now we have to go and update everything
Caption: so as long as we're not changing that
Caption: too much it will adjust with the grid it
Caption: can be pretty handy
Caption: and most of the browser Dev tools will
Caption: show you these numbers in this case it's
Caption: Firefox but you can inspect the element
Caption: and typically you can turn on line
Caption: numbers line names and other properties
Caption: like that
Caption: so the Modern Age have made prolific use
Caption: of this layering this is another example
Caption: of Hawkeye
Caption: and it can be a great way to finally
Caption: break out of the boxes that have
Caption: contained Us in design and layout for so
Caption: many years here's the web Recreation on
Caption: the other side that I've done
Caption: and we're not using Gap here we're just
Caption: adding some borders so that we can
Caption: because grid can't do sort of funky gaps
Caption: like that but we can overlay each of
Caption: them on there and then start to add some
Caption: borders and create some real interesting
Caption: depth into some of our designs
Caption: but
Caption: with great power comes great
Caption: responsibility
Caption: to keep with the theme of what I'm doing
Caption: layering is an exciting addition to our
Caption: layout toolboxes but we do have to
Caption: consider more than just the layout it
Caption: opens up to us there's an inherent
Caption: danger here when you can just position
Caption: something anywhere on the page
Caption: if the source order isn't created in a
Caption: way that makes sense you can negatively
Caption: impact the accessibility of your project
Caption: so as an example if we decided that the
Caption: panel 4 was better up the top we can
Caption: just do that we can move it with grid
Caption: but solely changing the visual layout is
Caption: not going to tell the browser
Caption: that the source order has changed so a
Caption: screen reader might come in and start to
Caption: go through that information by going the
Caption: first sort of few images to the girl to
Caption: the field
Caption: whereas we've now changed the visual
Caption: order to field and then the other things
Caption: going down so that's something that we
Caption: need to be careful of
Caption: to avoid falling into this trap there's
Caption: a few things that we can do we can look
Caption: at the structure of our document first
Caption: and make sure that we're layering it out
Caption: in HTML order correctly
Caption: we can then create the grid that
Caption: supports that and then like any hero be
Caption: vigilant and maintain that order when
Caption: you are working on these
Caption: a really good place to start reading
Caption: into grid accessibility is mdm's layout
Caption: and accessibility uh guide that they
Caption: have on the article on the website sorry
Caption: so a common criticism of web design and
Caption: layout is that everything is within a
Caption: box you may have heard it sort of the
Caption: reference to bootstrap layouts or maybe
Caption: a little bit of those libraries that
Caption: have helped us work fast but have
Caption: reduced some of the creativity that
Caption: we're able to get from these Frameworks
Caption: and so far looking at a lot of these
Caption: Comics we have some layering but
Caption: everything is still a box
Caption: now for Comics boxy layout started to
Caption: change during the Modern Age of comics
Caption: the characters broke out of their boxes
Caption: and the storytelling once again evolved
Caption: with them now this is a nice example
Caption: from Phoenix and Jean Gray
Caption: showing how different shapes can enhance
Caption: the storytelling and our recreated
Caption: example alongside it so that is running
Caption: and it is of a valid website
Caption: so fundamentally everything within a
Caption: grid is still going to be a box we can't
Caption: do random shapes like this
Caption: but we can combine our boxes with some
Caption: new techniques and get a bit creative
Caption: and give the illusion of almost any
Caption: shape that we like
Caption: so there's a little bit of boilerplate
Caption: in this we're setting up our comic to
Caption: contain everything we've got position
Caption: relative because we're going to do some
Caption: absolute positioning and floating and
Caption: things are going to get weird so we've
Caption: got overflow hidden on there as well to
Caption: make sure nothing escapes
Caption: we want it to break out of the box but
Caption: not too far I'm going to keep it in
Caption: there
Caption: now the panels grids has a column for
Caption: each of our five panels and they're just
Caption: regular panels going along like we've
Caption: seen before but we can only see a few of
Caption: the images and that's because we're
Caption: needing to overlap everything because
Caption: we're going to be cutting away some of
Caption: the image we need the other one sitting
Caption: underneath we can't have each one in its
Caption: own cell because if we go away and sort
Caption: of cut away the image the background is
Caption: going to show through where we want the
Caption: image
Caption: now hopefully to help visualize see this
Caption: is a layering that we're working with in
Caption: our grid in there
Caption: so our panel container is then rotated
Caption: and using absolute position so the
Caption: position along the bottom whereabouts we
Caption: want it and we've rotated it a little
Caption: bit and just sort of shimming it down
Caption: about where we want look the details
Caption: aren't super important we've put it down
Caption: there
Caption: so click path is what's going to enable
Caption: these shapes that we've wanted
Caption: when you add a clip path rule in this
Caption: case a polygon we have an X Y value for
Caption: each of those things and it makes its
Caption: way around the shape and that gives us
Caption: the image
Caption: now we can apply a clip path to each of
Caption: our images and then we've most of the
Caption: way there with what we were doing
Caption: now again we've got like all these
Caption: random numbers
Caption: on there and you're probably thinking
Caption: this still doesn't look easier
Caption: but Firefox has given us some great
Caption: tools here the dev tools are really
Caption: going to come in handy when you start
Caption: doing some things like this
Caption: if you select the icon in there
Caption: you can start to move the nodes around
Caption: yourself
Caption: and you can double click to add a new
Caption: node and start to drag that and you'll
Caption: see the values are updating in the dev
Caption: tools so to create this I was doing that
Caption: in the dev tools and then copying that
Caption: value across and adjusting as I need it
Caption: now for the white border we can't use
Caption: grid gut because everything's
Caption: overlapping so the Box the container has
Caption: a white background and then the same
Caption: clip path is added to the image but Jen
Caption: just shrunk down a little bit
Caption: and because we're doing that we need to
Caption: slightly tweak the transform origin
Caption: because we're dealing with some pretty
Caption: funny shapes here there's there's a lot
Caption: of little adjustments you'll need to do
Caption: when you start making shapes like this
Caption: but
Caption: that's one of the downsides of the
Caption: technique you're going to have to manage
Caption: the grid Gap manually yourself
Caption: but there we go we've recreated the
Caption: shapes from that comic which when you
Caption: initially look at it you would have
Caption: thought there's no way we can do that
Caption: sort of layer on the web
Caption: and if you haven't seen it yet each of
Caption: the links underneath it to the code pen
Caption: versions of each of these so you can
Caption: have a look at them and play but I have
Caption: a another Link at the end which will
Caption: link to all of them
Caption: so clip path is no doubt a powerful tool
Caption: when combined with grid so we're going
Caption: to have another example here which is
Caption: Detective Comics number 876
Caption: taking the grid layering and from our
Caption: earlier examples we can recreate this
Caption: same layout the drawing is a little more
Caption: intense but it's the layout in the
Caption: background we're going to focus on
Caption: Batman could be done by just the
Caption: layering that we looked at before
Caption: the shapes can be recreated by adding
Caption: perspective and rotating the panel so
Caption: we've added our grid we're adding a
Caption: panel to the Grid in similar ways that
Caption: we have before and then we transform we
Caption: use some perspective that gives us that
Caption: nice little angle and rotate it into
Caption: that and then the same with panel two
Caption: all the way down but you can see there's
Caption: a problem here in that the blue
Caption: background of each of them is coming
Caption: through we didn't want that we wanted
Caption: just the squares going down the page and
Caption: sort of forming one shape
Caption: again we can use clip path here to cut
Caption: out the part clip path is sort of
Caption: showing the part that we do want visible
Caption: so you're kind of doing you're not
Caption: cutting out the styles that you don't
Caption: you're making the part that you do want
Caption: visible but with each panel having a
Caption: clip path on it it gives the impression
Caption: of a border going all the way down while
Caption: giving us that shape so it's again
Caption: something quite interesting and
Caption: different for the web
Caption: so there it is next to Mr Batman
Caption: that clip path isn't limited to just
Caption: polygons there is a lot going on in
Caption: these images but we have flash on the
Caption: side and I particularly enjoy the cats
Caption: up the top here
Caption: looks like Too Faced to keep with our
Caption: comic book thing so we've got our
Caption: polygons that we've seen
Caption: but
Caption: there are some other options ellipse
Caption: allows for oval shape again the first
Caption: two values are our radius and then the X
Caption: and Y allows us to offset it a little
Caption: bit
Caption: and circle for a more uniform shape
Caption: similar to ellipse the first value is a
Caption: radius followed by the position and we
Caption: can have something else
Caption: so clip path affected the shape of the
Caption: container but we can also have the text
Caption: react to the shape of the container as
Caption: well using CSS shapes
Caption: this is a panel from Saga and the part
Caption: that's important here is how the moon
Caption: has its curve or the planet and then the
Caption: text is also curving along that now this
Caption: has existed in magazines for a long time
Caption: but it's been absent for from the web
Caption: but again we'll do a little bit of setup
Caption: here we have our panel position relative
Caption: because we're moving things about again
Caption: our paragraph We shift it into place and
Caption: the important part here is our image
Caption: which we've moved to the side we could
Caption: have done this with grid as well the
Caption: width and the height but the shape
Caption: outside is what we're interested in the
Caption: circle
Caption: so Firefox again has been helping us
Caption: developers out with the dev tools we can
Caption: apply a shape outside and just use some
Caption: values
Caption: but then we can select that icon and
Caption: start resizing in real time and I've I'm
Caption: certainly a visual kind of a learner and
Caption: I like to see things happening with code
Caption: maybe that's why I prefer the front end
Caption: but
Caption: we can see that and we can take those
Caption: values and we can move it back to our
Caption: CSS so it's really nice that the tools
Caption: are helping us with this creative coding
Caption: side of things I didn't mean to skip but
Caption: we'll move on
Caption: the shapes can also be more complex than
Caption: just circles so
Caption: there is definitely going to be a moment
Caption: in your career where a designer comes to
Caption: you and says we've got a cat
Caption: and we need the text to wrap around it
Caption: and you go I saw these ones
Caption: and so we can use the polygon shape that
Caption: we've had before and we can draw around
Caption: our cat and we can do that
Caption: now we can also with something that clip
Caption: path didn't allow us but shape outside
Caption: does is use an alpha mark So if we have
Caption: our cat and then we have an alpha mass
Caption: that represents the shape of our cat
Caption: very similar to a background image we
Caption: can say shape outside URL cat mask
Caption: there's some cause funniness in here but
Caption: that's boring this is kind of what we're
Caption: going to look at here and you can look
Caption: at the cause problems later it needs to
Caption: be on the same domain essentially
Caption: so what we've created is a great example
Caption: of the modern web but it is based on a
Caption: western modern web it's Western Comics
Caption: Styles and structures
Caption: that's reading left to right top to
Caption: bottom
Caption: the structure and reading style isn't
Caption: the only comic structure that exists
Caption: though for instance Japan has a very
Caption: healthy industry with its manga
Caption: now I've been a particular fan of Naruto
Caption: for a while so it's fun again that I get
Caption: to just keep putting all of my hobbies
Caption: into this talk
Caption: but this is the same page from the manga
Caption: in Japanese and in English now even with
Caption: the English one we can see that the
Caption: start is on the other side to what we're
Caption: used to and it finishes on the other
Caption: side of there but the English version
Caption: even though it's translated they kept
Caption: the layout the same uh
Caption: we could position the cells in our grid
Caption: in this way quite
Caption: straightforward but we'll remember from
Caption: before
Caption: The Source order matters so if we were
Caption: to have alt text and everything on here
Caption: if we were to put it in that order then
Caption: the screen reader is going to read it
Caption: somewhat backwards more from the top
Caption: down to the other side oops
Caption: so when placed into the grid with a left
Caption: to right direction we can do it like so
Caption: we'll have our first panel second third
Caption: through to the sixth so similar to at
Caption: least in my experience a reading style
Caption: that I'm used to
Caption: grid has us really well covered for
Caption: internationalization when direction
Caption: right to left is applied this can be in
Caption: multiple places in the page but I've
Caption: done it directly here on the main
Caption: grid just flips it to what right to left
Caption: is so panel one is now over to the side
Caption: two three four five so we've covered the
Caption: accessibility by putting it in the
Caption: correct order we've added our grid but
Caption: then we've enabled other styles with a
Caption: simple property
Caption: so of interest in this comic you'll
Caption: notice the difference in Grid gaps
Caption: in the example you can do that as well
Caption: with a grid Gap it doesn't always have
Caption: to be consistent in here we're affecting
Caption: the horizontal and the vertical Gap
Caption: what's also worth noting in the manga is
Caption: that the text runs vertically but in
Caption: English it's left to right
Caption: now I didn't want to attempt to write
Caption: Japanese so I did it with English and
Caption: you do get a bit of a weird thing where
Caption: the text runs that way but with writing
Caption: mode vertical right to left it will go
Caption: in the direction that someone like that
Caption: would be expecting
Caption: with the logographic typeset such as
Caption: what Japanese has that will work out uh
Caption: correctly
Caption: not actually sure why it does that with
Caption: English but I'm sure there's a really
Caption: valid explanation
Caption: so that brings us to the end of our
Caption: journey through the ages of comic and
Caption: how they can be brought to the web
Caption: I mentioned at the start that although
Caption: the examples are for Comics to think
Caption: about how you can apply these to the
Caption: projects that you're working on and I
Caption: hope the various effects that I've
Caption: demonstrated have sort of sparked some
Caption: ideas of something different that you
Caption: can do with layout
Caption: and taking it to the everyday products
Caption: of the web
Caption: we've been in these layout boxes for
Caption: quite some time so imagine when you
Caption: apply these layouts to your projects
Caption: sort of great things will start to
Caption: happen
Caption: and that's why I believe we're now in
Caption: the Modern Age of the layout on the web
Caption: CSS grid gives us great new powers and
Caption: flexibility with our layout we saw how
Caption: we could stagger content layer our
Caption: panels to create depth and interest the
Caption: coming CSS grid level 2 spec will give
Caption: us the ability with subgrid to align
Caption: better across multiple panels
Caption: and getting a little more creative and
Caption: breaking out of the layout box the CSS
Caption: shapes clip path and shape outside
Caption: making our projects as accessible to as
Caption: wide an audience as possible with Grid's
Caption: great support for internationalization
Caption: I mentioned earlier that the code pens
Caption: were all available this is the URL where
Caption: you can find them and I also have it
Caption: linked on my Twitter if you want to have
Caption: a play around with those
Caption: in a torque setting it can be hard to
Caption: get through everything did you get the
Caption: photo do you want me to go back
Caption: uh it can be hard to get through
Caption: everything in a torque setting so I've
Caption: written blog posts that go through each
Caption: one of those areas and it goes into a
Caption: lot more detail than what is possible in
Caption: a talk so that can be useful for you as
Caption: well
Caption: so Stan Lee had a famous catchphrase he
Caption: used to sign off letters and
Caption: correspondence that he had with fans
Caption: which was Excelsior and as a little bit
Caption: of a hat tip I thought it would be nice
Caption: to include that in my talk as a closing
Caption: he's had a great effect on many comic uh
Caption: sorry in many creative Industries and
Caption: but after looking up at meaning I sort
Caption: of thought it was a really fantastic way
Caption: to finish a talk
Caption: Excelsior stands for ever upwards so I
Caption: think take what you learn from this talk
Caption: and all the other great talks today and
Caption: see how you can apply that to what
Caption: you're working with
Caption: thanks very much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you so much for that amazing talk
Caption: Anton we've got about five minutes for
Caption: questions
Caption: hey uh thanks for the presentation it's
Caption: very good
Caption: um it's my Fisto in MCU
Caption: what was that so it's Mephisto it's
Caption: gonna be an MCU
Caption: h
Caption: I can't do any of their stuff on the web
Caption: so I have a question what would you
Caption: advise is the best approach to take for
Caption: somebody new to using something like CSS
Caption: grid
Caption: well I mean what this is the way that I
Caption: learned CSS grid it was the talk is a
Caption: little bit older now
Caption: um
Caption: but linking it with something that you
Caption: enjoy I think is a good way to learn it
Caption: I I kind of use some of these comics and
Caption: and looked at the layouts and I was
Caption: trying to use Grid in products
Caption: that designers would send me but it was
Caption: always trying to visualize something
Caption: that I didn't quite understand yet
Caption: because the the layouts that they were
Caption: doing didn't have these grids and these
Caption: structures to it so taking a bit of a
Caption: step back and starting to work with grid
Caption: with comics in my case
Caption: uh was nice because it could start off
Caption: quite simple and then build up to our
Caption: more advanced uh examples with the sort
Caption: of breaking out the boxes and starting
Caption: to combine those techniques together
Caption: so yeah I would say link it with
Caption: something that you enjoy doing
Caption: I think that's good advice for
Caption: everything really yes
Caption: um if there's no other questions can we
Caption: please have another round of applause
Caption: for Anton
Caption: and it is now lunch time I'm sure
Caption: everyone's hanging out for food